HANK: Good morning, John!
I live in a city that most people would call
a small town.
Missoula, Montana has 70,000 people in it
when the students are here, and when they
leave for the summer, the population declines
significantly.
Somehow, 70,000 people is considered to be
a small number of people.
It actually is quite a large number of people,
but, I mean, after all there are some cities
that have stadiums that hold more than 70,000
people, so.
For some perspective, Missoula packs those
70,000 people into 2600 square miles.
Manhattan has 22 times more people in 78 times
less area.
And, of course, there are many amazing things
going on in Manhattan.
It isn't just 1.3 million people.
It's 1.3 million of the richest, most powerful,
most influential people on the planet.
Economic and cultural creation on the scale
of Renaissance Italy.
And that is an interesting comparison because
Florence in 1500 contained some of the most
powerful economic and cultural forces the
world has ever known.
The Medici bankers, Botticelli, Machiavelli,
Michaelangelo, da Vinci, Brunelleschi.
It revolutionized the world from the seat
of the Renaissance in Florence, Italy.
And what was the population of Florence, Italy?
1.3 million people?
No.
No millions of people!
No hundreds of thousands of people!
70,000.
Of course there were tremendous political
and economic and cultural and historic forces
that made Florence the seat of the Renaissance.
But one thing that I believe very deeply in
my heart, and I think most historians would
agree with me, is that it didn't happen because
there was just some random collection of really
great people.
Great people are everywhere all the time.
It just so happens that only occasionally
our cultural and historical and economic forces,
such that they will be remembered for hundreds
or even thousands of years.
So I like to think of Missoula as like a little
Florence.
And everyone walking around is an unnoticed
da Vinci and an unmade Machiavelli.
And I think about what separates the great
people that I remember from the great people
that everyone remembers.
I think it's 100% circumstance.
We're launching a new channel this week with
Jessi Knudsen Castañeda and her husband Augusto,
who you may know from their frequent appearances
on SciShow.
They bring to us animals that they have rescued
so that we can talk about them and educate
the world.
That's Jessi's passion!
That's her superpower.
And Caitlin Hoffmeister, who's also the producer
of SciShow, is going to be documenting the
passion, and sweat, and toil that it takes
to run a small business and feed hundreds
of mouths.
Two of those mouths happen to be twin infant
children.
Now that I've produced shows with a bunch
of different interesting people here in Missoula--Emily
Graslie, and Lindsey Doe, and now Jessi--people
have asked me why are there so many interesting
things going on in this one little small town
in Missoula?
That's the thing, though!
That's the point!
There's interetsting things happening everywhere!
This isn't a magical place and they're not
magical people.
It's just people who have found something
that they're passionate about.
But yeah, that can be a hard thing to come
by.
I've watched everyone I've ever known struggle
with that.
Trying to find something that they believe
is important.
And I'm so grateful--changing topics here,
really fast--that Nerdfighteria has provided
that for me.
People talk about all the things that I've
been able to do.
But it is only because I found something here
that I can believe in.
Because, yeah, I live in Missoula, Montana,
but my first allegiance is to this place.
A community of hundreds of thousands of people
with shared ideas, and values and interests.
Bigger than Missoula and thus even more full
of unappreciated and unnoticed da Vincis and
Machiavellis and Brunelleschis.
The only difference between something being
vitally important, and not important at all,
is whether or not you believe it is.
I believe that this is important, and that
is a gift that you have given me.
Thank you!
John, your life seems like a bit of a grapefruit
right now.
Don't freak out.
Uhh, stay sane.
And I'll see you on Tuesday.
If you want to check out Jessi's new channel,
there's a link in the description.
And there's also you can just click over here
if you're not on your phone, you can click
with your mouse.
But not with your phone, it doesn't work on
phones.
Boop.